This is Al Brooks and this is my price action trading course. This module is about my setup.
It's pretty simple. I use a laptop computer and it's not particularly expensive. It's
a very average laptop. I use a five minute candle chart and a 20 bar exponential moving
average and I do not use any indicators. So for example here is a daily chart of the
EWZ. I have a 20 bar exponential moving average. Since this is a daily chart, each bar is one
day so the 20 bar exponential moving average is a 20 day moving average in this particular
case. On a five minute chart the 20 bar exponential moving average would be five 20 minute. When
I look at the five minute chart, here is a five minute chart of PBR Petrobras and when
I look at the five minute chart I have my 20 bar exponential moving average but I usually
have two other moving averages as well. This one is also a 20 bar moving average but it's
based upon the 15 minute chart. So in other words it's based upon 20 15 minute bars and
this other line is also a 20 bar exponential moving average but it's based on the 60 minute
chart. In other words this line is exactly at the prices that I would see the line on
a 60 minute chart. So it's helpful. So here you can see the market is forming a double
top at the 60 minute moving average. So if this was a 60 minute bar chart this would
be right at the 60 minute moving average. I keep my blinds closed. I don't take calls
and I don't watch television. Occasionally I'll get a phone call from one of my daughters
or one of my sons and I'll take that call but otherwise I don't take calls and I ignore
the news. I ignore the pundits. I know when there are reports at 7 o'clock or an FOMC
report and when the reports come out I usually do not trade at least for several seconds
maybe for several minutes. I don't care what the pundits say. The report means there's
going to be a bullish case and a bearish case and they're going to put one pundit on and
that pundit will be either a bull or a bear and that's not telling me what the two or
300 firms who are trading aggressively think that the market is doing in response to the
report. The only way I know how the market thinks the report is by looking at the charts
pundit on television is only giving me one side. Also I don't want any distractions and
I don't want anybody else's opinions. I just want to analyze what's going on myself and
I'm also very focused on it. What's my job? It's simple. It's to take money from other
people's accounts and to put it into my account. We're all playing the same game. It's no secret.
Everyone's trying to take money from everyone else. Goldman Sachs is trying to take money
from Morgan Stanley. Morgan Stanley is trying to take money from Citibank. Hedge funds are
trying to take money from everybody else. That's just the game that we're playing.
I have a 60-40 rule and sometimes on television you'll see someone insisting that the market
is definitely going up or definitely going down or some report is definitely bullish
or bearish. Nothing works all of the time. Everything works some of the time. Most things
work 40 to 60% of the time. I think we live in a world where the probability is 40 to
60%. Allen Greenspan once said that he was very proud that he was right about 70% of
the time. Here he is, the chairman of the Fed, and he's making the rules and he's controlling
the game and even with that he could still be right only 70% of the time. Most people
who are traders are going to live in a world where the probability is 40 to 60%. If you
think something is higher than that, you're probably wrong. If you think something is
less likely than 40%, you're probably wrong. If things get outside of that band, there
will not be institutions taking the other side of the trade and they'll hammer it back
into the band. Remember, the market stays pretty much in balance. There'll be an equal
number, or approximately an equal number of institutions on one side as there are on
the other side. If the market gets too heavy on one side, it will regress toward the mean.
Whenever someone says that he has something better than 60-40, there are certain pundits
that they put on television who talk with certainty that something is going to happen.
I never believe them. Whenever a person is that certain or confident, he is not honest
and he's out there selling something. Perfect trades cannot exist because there has to be
institutions taking the other side. If something was perfect, perfectly right, that means the
other institutions would have to be perfectly wrong. Since these institutions are pretty
much balanced on both sides, it would be impossible for that to happen. How can price action trading
work if everyone knows it? Trading is very difficult to do. Even when you're very good,
your margin for error is very small and every mistake works against you.
The best analysis is right only about 60-70% of the time. I often have days when I don't
lose it all. That doesn't mean I'm 100% right. It just means I was lucky on that day. Really
good traders, for the most part, are not going to be right more than 70% of the time unless
they're scalpers. I scalp most of the time. I do try to swing during the day, but most
of my trades are scalps. That's the only way you can get a high winning percentage. You're
competing against the very best traders in the world, the smartest people in the world,
and it's basically a zero-sum game. Everyone wants to take money from everyone else.
There's a huge difference between knowing how to do something really well and playing
it well enough to make a living. A soccer player, he may know how to play, for example,
a coach, but that does not mean he's able to make a living doing it. You can know a
lot about trading, but you have to have a lot of experience to be able to trade well
enough to make a living. Who's the mark in poker you often hear about? That guy's the
mark. In poker, if you're playing poker and you're with a table, six people, eight people,
and you don't know who the mark is, who the loser is, then you're probably the mark. In
trading, someone is always trapped on the wrong side of the market. If you don't know who's
trapped, you'll probably discover that you're trapped, that you're on the wrong side and
you're holding a losing position. It's very important to understand that 60-40 rule. If
you don't believe that the exact opposite can happen, the exact opposite of what you
believe will happen, if you don't believe that the exact opposite can happen 40% of the
time, you'll be trapped into bad positions and out of good positions. You have to be
very fluid about this and with your beliefs, you have to change when the market is giving
you evidence that your current belief is wrong, just take the opposite belief and there's
nothing wrong with that. The market does that all the time. It's always reversing all day
long. You should change your opinion all day long repeatedly.
Can you get trapped out of a good trade? Sure. Here's a strong bull trend. You've got several
strong bars and some bulls would have exited below this strong bear bar, especially since
it's the second bear bar. If you were one of those traders who exited out because of
all these bear bodies and then you see a potential buy signal, just get right back in. If you
get trapped out of a good trade, you just get right back in. Don't feel embarrassed about
it. That's just the way the market works. It's always trying to trap traders out. If
you see that you were wrong in believing that the trade was bad, that a long trade was bad
and you got another buy signal, just go ahead and buy. Don't worry. This is the end of the
module on my setup.